et que patrie box médecin généraliste
vous soirée hot merci d'être avec nous
vous étiez l'un des premiers à donner
l'alertent en mars 2020 sur le co vide
aujourd'hui vous tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé sur le manque de dos puisque on
le rappelle vous êtes médecin à mulhouse
mulhouse
l'une des toutes premières villes très
frappé par la pandémie
oui mulhouse a été frappé de plein fouet
en marge 2020 exactement ça a été le
départ d'épidémie actuellement le
constat qu'on peut faire c'est que les
médecins sont sous dotées de vaccins on
en a peut pas assez il ya une rupture de
stock on est les livraisons sont
différées et surtout nous n'avons pas
accès aux vaccins arn donc le modern and
the prize est rond n'y a pas accès c'est
dire qu'on est vraiment limité dans la
capacité de vacciner les gens fragiles
que nous voyons en danger et pour les
mettre à l'abri avec la vaccination
je ne comprends pas bien pourquoi votre
région n'a pas accès aux vaccins arn
alors je ne sais pas il ya eu 1
apparemment ce que j'ai entendu c'est
que la moselle en serait doté un peu de
modern art mais pour l'instant
l'ensemble des médecins j'ai ris de
france ne sont pas dotés des vaccins
allen voulait venir uniquement chez les
médecins parce que ça effectivement le
sait puisqu'il ya des problèmes de de
conservation difficile avec notamment le
phaser en revanche on dispose miens de
l'astra zeneca vous en tant que médecin
généraliste
oui on à l'extra zeneca mais qui est à
ce jour très limité parce que ces
dernières semaines nous avons droit un
flacons de dix doses
donc c'est très très peu et encore il ya
quinze jours on n'avait pas été dotée du
tout quant au vaccin moderna j'ai
entendu ce que disait monsieur atteint
effectivement nous avons pu commander un
flacon de cinq doses
hier mais il sera livré le 22 et 23
avril donc la semaine prochaine et donc
aux prêts à vacciner seulement la
semaine d'après parce que les vaccins on
n'organise pas comme ça les vaccinations
à vendredi après midi ça s'organise à
partir du lundi
ça veut dire qu'à partir du 26 27 avril
nous pourrons utiliser nos cinq doses de
vaccin johnson mike sendall on va pas
très loin
autant qu'en plus le astrazeneca on le
sait c'est un petit peu le voilà le
vaccin maudit en ce moment le danemark a
annoncé aujourd'hui sa suspension
l'europe a d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'elle ne commanderait plus l'année
prochaine
il ya il y a une vraie suspicion de
votre côté également chez vos patients
sur ce vaccin ou les mulhousiens ce
convient volontiers vacciner y compris
avec ce vaccin là ça devient autre temps
difficiles pour convaincre les gens
alors ce qu'on leur dit c'est très
simple c'est 4 au delà de 50 ans en gros
n'a pas vu d'effets secondaires de type
coagulation chez les gens donc on peut
les gens de plus de 50 ans 55 ans de
toute façon on peut utiliser le vaccin
en toute sécurité pour les jeunes bien
sûr on ne le fait pas d'autant plus que
les gens sont très réticents et ne
veulent pas le faire
ils ne veulent pas le faire est une très
grande réticence même si les gens qui
seraient éligibles les gens de plus de
55 ans qui seraient éligibles aux
vaccins commence à devenir très
dubitatif et il faut vraiment beaucoup
d'arguments pour les convaincre à se
faire vacciner dans nos cabinets sa de
hand ou gif entre les changements
constants de cible de deux stratégies de
pénurie de vaccins et maintenant le
refus des patients
ça devient vraiment très dur pour nous
les jeunes à risque de continuer la
vaccination on est vraiment très
désabusée ces derniers temps vous
craignez le même phénomène
je rappelle que ce vaccin a été mis en
pause aux états unis après après le
cadre de citron beauce dont d'ailleurs
un mort en france on a 200 mille doses
mais pour le moment on ne sait pas trop
vous craignez en fait les suites de ce
vaccin également c'était à mon avis tout
à fait prévisible il semblerait bien que
ce soit un effet lié au vaccin
adénovirus qui provoque ce genre de
thrombose à rester extrêmement
restreinte pasqua bien aux états unis il
ya eu sur 6 millions de doses vaccinales
distribuer il ya eu je crois
trois ou quatre accidents c'est
extrêmement peu on est bien d'accord
c'est moins grave que de prendre la
pilule et tubes et en même temps qui est
beaucoup plus dangereux mais les gens ne
veulent pas le comprendre il ne veulent
pas accepter qu'un vaccin qui est là
pour les protéger pourraient être
toxiques
pourtant il va bien falloir qu'on fasse
quelque chose parce que la stratégie
vaccinale tech 1 basé ce vaccin
adénovirus pour vacciner dans les mois
qui viennent la population jeune et
active et donc ça va poser un problème
évident comment ça se passe
dr valdes au sein de l'ue vaccinodromes
de mulhouse est ce que les choses sont
un peu plus apaisé
ça se passe mieux que dans mon cabinet
de généraliste alors je crois que deux
heures je sais pas trop ce qui s'y passe
parce que j'y travaille pas parce que je
suis occupé dans mon cabinet c'est un
choix on a si j'ai choisi de vacciner
intensivement cabinet
même si on n'arrive plus j'ai quand même
réussi à faire près de 180 vaccins en un
mois maintenant ça va beaucoup plus
lentement
je crois que dans les vaccinodromes ils
ont accès a choisi mans tous les vaccins
le fight the modern à l'astral je crois
qu'ils en ont aussi donc je sais pas on
n'est pas sur le même pied d'égalité
très honnêtement malheureusement aura
bientôt franchir les 100 mille morts en
france
alors qu'on parle de déconfinement
emmanuel mettrons en ligne en ce sens
demain déconfinement mi mai c'est ce
qu'on nous avait promis un plus ou moins
le chef de l'état vous croyez que c'est
toujours possible
je t'ai pas je suis un peu inquiet comme
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il faut
or on a très bien compris qu'il fallait
accélérer la vaccination il fallait que
toutes les vies pour ce vide sanitaire
soient assis sur la vaccination
on voit que les médecins légistes on a
un peu mis de côté et puis on voit qu'il
ya deux de 25 ans sont tout de même
importants pour cette vaccination
l'asra et le johnson sont créés ralenti
donc il va falloir définir
de vaccination convaincre la population
je suis dit peut-être essayer d'aller un
peu plus vite
une dernière question rapidement sur ces
variants le variant brésiliens notamment
qui fait si peur en tant que co médecin
vous l'appréhendez comment on nous dit
que c'est sa force en france aujourd'hui
alors il ya tant dans le grand est c'est
pas mal de variantes sont variés anglais
est majoritaire et jeu pro dernières
données de la rs il y avait enfin qu'ils
consentent de variants brésilien et
africain on voit pas beaucoup d'effet en
cours c'est sûr que il a été déconseillé
de vacciner avec le vaccin astra en
moselle et donc chaque développe le
modern a intensivement chez nous dans le
grand est à mulhouse on n'a pas encore
vu vraiment de résistance aux vaccins
astra mais on n'a pas beaucoup de
chiffres non plus de retombées quoi il
s'assoupit évidemment merci beaucoup
patrick wincke messin jeunes et inclura
nullos d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france